it leaks in the Yemeni press that the
dictator of Yemen's going to pardon of
the little Hydra Shia that day he gets a
phone call from the White House not from
some undersecretary or you know some
assistant to the president President
Obama personally calls him and says that
the United States is deeply concerned
about reports that you're going to
release of the level header style the
pardon is then ripped up and he remains
in prison to this moment when I'm
talking to you we're in an environment
where the Associated Press had its phone
records seized not just on one or two
reporters but on you know dozens of
phone lines where there were these the
attempt to imply criminal conduct was
committed on the part of James Rosen
this fox news journalist you have
whistleblowers that are being targeted
by this White House in record numbers
and you have the President of the United
States constitutional law professor
Nobel Peace Prize winner keeping a
respected Yemeni journalist in prison
seemingly because he had that he
committed the crime of doing actual
journalism and the thing to me that sort
of outrageous you know outrage upon
outrage is that none of the big US media
outlets that he did work for that were
happy to run his content the washington
post-abc news NBC news none of them have
said a thing about his case that's
shameful